clap clap clap clap
happy Monday we're here with Beth
Morosky in the chat room Jason O'Malley
creeper in the corner I'm wearing my
Banksy dismaland shirt amazing theme
park if you haven't been there please go
today we're doing something that's
extremely exciting we're playing a
little mini Nintendo that's right we're
so lucky that we got this little piece
of heaven right here it's got 30 games
on it it is going to be the hottest
thing this Christmas I'm sure look at
this little guy look at the tiniest
little thing this little thing it's so
small let's let swap got a reset button
there got a little power button this
thing doesn't open so you can't blow on
it but for old times sake I guess you
still could ah two controllers we only
have one and it's got HDMI in the back
look for all you nerds there's what the
back looks like I'm very pumped it's got
the old-school controller here and these
shortest cable known to man doesn't even
reach Beth's face look if I want to hit
her in the face I can't do it if I want
to hit her in the face I can't do it
she'd have to lean forward and help me
ah a mirror we got this thing it was
sent to us we're extremely lucky I tried
to go and get it myself when it came out
last week and I went to target at like
9:00 in the morning target opens at 8:00
and I was kind of like skulking around a
little bit and I this guy comes up he's
like hey you guys got any nintendo's and
he was like 30 years old and just
weathered and he was drinking a coffee
and the guy's like we sold out 15
minutes after we opened sorry the guy
runs like jets away because it was like
in the mall in Glendale and he was
headed to the GameStop which opened at
10:00 another guy I'm bout to leave
another guy comes up I hear him ask oh
my god I didn't even go to gamestop I
was like what's the point I'm just gonna
go sit outside gamestop to be
disappointed no thanks so yeah it's a
mess ah Duke Lewis gamer again says Sep
Garcia you know what there's a clueless
gamer tonight everybody tonight we play
we're gonna be playing a little bit of
Final Fantasy 15 with this cat this cat
right here this cat this cat right here
this cat with the
sky right there there you go good old
Elijah would Frodo himself or uh well
the Wilfred guy from Dirk Gently that
guy anyway Elijah Wood and me and Conan
I'll play Final Fantasy 15 ride some
chocobos spoiler alert and a couple
hours it's gonna be on the internet cuz
we're taping early today walk a walk a
bear ski you know what I'm talking about
any Sonic games that's Genesis dude get
your [ __ ] right come on you dicks
um one cool thing about this is so
here's all the games we got one kind of
cool thing about this the little NES is
you can save your game which is mind
blowing it's actually very cool you can
you can save your game you can save
actually four different things right
here see and it's called suspend point
which is kind of cool I like your hair
Thank You Adam strange I like yours
what a dick this is willie mae i am a
dick that's true
but yes you can save your game which is
kind of fun and then this is kind of fun
too let's just go through this you can
play three different kinds here so you
can play pixel perfect which is actually
how how the games were made four by
three right and you can play with the
CRT filter which is what we're gonna do
and it actually simulates what it looks
like on an old television so that's
right either finish the game with what's
sitting or get the [ __ ] out all right
fair enough greetings from bosnia
alright pretty cool right so we're gonna
play the CRT filter so what game should
we play here let's try to beat it one go
what do you think I always wanted to
play Ninja Gaiden for Gaiden
I don't know let's play this though just
tuned in does this have Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles it doesn't actually hey
Mouse could you move the chat over a
little bit so I can see it I love you to
the 90 guy I marry you the p90 guy maybe
yeah what can you offer me in hand in
marriage oh dude you remember this this
is such a battle
I think because we're avenging our
Father isn't that how this game goes wow
they're sending a lot of running oh
there we go
what about whom did father have a duel
and lose
for what reason did he fight and die
even I don't know for sure this is what
game this is when Kings meant something
you know what I'm saying
whoo-hoo isn't that sad music have Konev
play the first legend zelda the debtor
disappeared his father's room i found a
letter addressed to me it said REO I'm
on my way to a life-or-death duel look
at that sweet dealt though sweet Beltre
there but it's destiny die not return
you were to take the dragon sword of the
Hayabusa family and go to America and
see the archaeologist Walter Smith okay
by the way this is the same guy in
Street Fighter 2 I think right always be
brave for your guy who hasn't grown up
that's me I will get my revenge
his games I miss back when I was a kid
look at me Alex a guest Cortney patents
in the stream can't can't listen to it
but she's watching so I'm gonna say hi
Courtney let's do it man 1989 40 years
she wasn't alive she was born in 2011
[ __ ] here we go oh my god alright let's
all right let's go
easy I love it they just come at you
like this you know what's interesting
about these games this is actually oh I
forgot I can oh that's like oh that's
right can I jump on that thing I just
naturally cling to this oh I'm so gonna
die you guys um okay one thing that's
kind of cool about these old games I
read this article I think I've probably
said this before in here oh man
by the way this this controller bites
into your knuckles butts in your palms
like you wouldn't believe
no a nice guy where am I at now why
would somebody try to punch me when I
have a sword
I read this article about Super Meat Boy
which is kind of interesting you know
Super Meat Boy is kind of this
old-school
eighties game and it kind of said that
you know in these old games you know
nowadays you get power-ups and stuff
like that but these old games you're
powering up yourself because you just
have to get better which is kind of
interesting I kind of like that idea
like wow
well played put put the hurt not him
Beth is whoa cos [ __ ] by the way so woke
good I slept a lot this weekend so now
I'm very awoke that's right
I need to leave you need to leave oh
that's right oh that's right you can do
the shooting of the fire and [ __ ] forgot
about this it seems like it's pretty
flimsy
I can't yeah hey we only have one Abbie
Hey I don't think it's flit I think it's
actually pretty sturdy I live I have a
time limit wait what the [ __ ] oh that's
some [ __ ] oh there's a time limit no
that is oh my god I only have 150
seconds to get through this level this
is crap alright enough [ __ ] around
just skip all these dudes right why do I
need to do any of this you know what I
think in my younger eat okay
I'm just getting railed by the knife guy
oh come on nice dude oh come on I think
of my younger years I would have fought
everybody but now I realize the value
and just jumping over people you know I
don't know if it's wisdom or laziness
but that's what it is
III guys it's been like 20 30 years
since I've played this game I guess it
can't be 30 can it because this was in
99
I do it you know what I appreciate the
timer though it's like kids don't waste
your time on this game you know like get
through get through it just get over it
you know
yeah it's now it's like you can't play
ninja gaiden is it ninja gaiden or
gaiden all right after you all right
there we go we got past it all right I
didn't realize there was a timer I've
never seen I haven't seen Steven Seagal
in the last 24 hours
by the way my friend used to be Steven
Seagal's uh used to be Steven Seagal's
personal assistant can I jump over you
please
that's all this dude does this is the
boss he says before he gets killed I'm
almost dead by the way
I'm definitely killed these teaser boss
oh oh we start back here this sucks
oh my god the thing is I'm actually
gonna I think have to try
I'm getting better guys yeah I think
when I die what should I play thanks
guys let's hear it
ohh oh my god these games you know maybe
this is gonna have to be like a personal
challenge on my own channel or I just
try to beat this because I don't think
I'm gonna be able to beat this in one
sitting as a kid I could never get past
the second-to-last guy when you have to
fight
sorry spoiler alert your own father
turns out he doesn't die all right I'm
gonna save the old spheal spinning blade
for this this last guy oh you know I was
never a curvy guy I never played Kirti
Zelda maybe what about some Double
Dragon we could try to play some double
dragon con would be great but they only
have super contra on here nice look how
far that guy threw that knife all right
oh my god
you guys are [ __ ] all right let's go
Battletoads
I don't think Battletoads is on here I
love Battletoads oh oh but guess the
right thing to do is to have that
spinning blade it took two hits both
help
all right we're gonna play some Super
Mario but which Super Mario who are they
they seem to be following me this is
game is pure intensity you think West
world is good try playing some Ninja
Gaiden guys who's there ah it's Sean
Young from Blade Runner it's just a girl
oh this game might be two sexes I willed
it first Oh
ooh damn that's what you get
superhot I'm seen Super Mario 2 I'm
sleeping Super Mario 3 all right as soon
as I die we're doing - I'm seeing Super
Mario - how sure this is the NES cord
sure here's how sure it is ready it is 3
feet my arms 3 feet long it's exactly 3
feet it's not long like we had to put
this thing on the floor also it only
comes with one controller which kind of
sucks but whatever I'll beat Bethan time
here take this ooh this statue take this
legally just different enough from the
aliens Franchise statutes there where
you can't sue us there's no time to
explain by the way there's always time
to explain
there's always time to explain you know
like that's what Wesen like that's what
the West Wing did well they just they
explain stuff while walking yep you
don't have to sit here and talk you can
just explain why you're you just you
walk and talk
sore can figure it up all right let's go
oh my god guys this is bringing me back
these guys with bats and motorcycle
helmets I'm sorry it's dumb it's a dumb
idea no booze yet although if the grant
comes through all those bats
oh I'm just remembering how much of this
[ __ ] I've blocked out when I was a kid
how much pain did I go through nope no
thanks sorry demon dog later skater
these games are absurdly hard
they're coming back to me though guys
coming back in force nope
go [ __ ] yourself there's another super
hard game Castlevania was I do
appreciate that every guy just dies by
you just hit him once with your sword
and that's it also the time limits crazy
keeps things moving why do they put a
time limit on this Aaron you look good
only kale drinks for you that's true
only kill drinks for this guy oh come on
what ok Super Mario Brothers 2 it is
game over here by the way is how you get
here's how you go back to the main
screen you just hit reset and then see
over in the corner there in the corner
below us that's how you save your game
so I'm gonna save it I'm gonna come back
that's right boom I could just start
there
screw you ninja guy and I'll beat you
yet alright let's go
see and then it tells you you have a
save game here oh you know what I think
you must have four saved games for each
game that's awesome oh we gotta place a
punch out guys punch out then Super
Mario 2 yeah alright quick punch out oh
man I say hmm this is awesome Caroline
you got to get this ah you stuff I do
have a gamer I do have a channel for me
it's just air and blared it's really
easy really easy to figure out this is
the yes this is the if you guys are
joining us for playing the new classic
mini nes thing it's amazing there's 30
games on here you could save you've got
4 save slots per game which is awesome
so you might actually have a chance to
beat a single Nintendo King here we go
guys this is gonna be just like the
Conor McGregor fight it's Conan I get to
beat the [ __ ] on the Conan you guys
that's gonna happen yeah just like Kony
he's got white old hips this cord is
super short by the way but it's okay
Batman is smaller
yep no way clatters glass Jojo here he
comes
oh I go low then I go up then I go low
then I go low then I go up we get a
little start pop pop pop pop boom rap
rap rap stay down
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
where you at homes where you at I just
mix it up you know this is like me and
the streets and me and the sheets nope
sorry oh yeah how do you super punch in
this oh oh start oh yeah no it's start
you're right yeah last Jojo say my name
Paul Berger say my name say my name
there you go better glass gym is 12 feet
tall heesu nobody realizes it but it
you're actually like fighting and gets
mutants this game watches left I'm
watching it bro watch the John Doe to
hit my jaw round - you're going down bro
you check out Tyson because of licensee
it's a made-up character the same planet
so yeah mr. dream well you know what I
heard somebody say you can buy at one
point mr. dream or Mike Tyson's
punch-out at the same time that's just
because there was like leftover stock
where you been miss me brother who's the
girl she can't be here this is for that
nerd guy Oh me dunk machine listen beats
murasky runs this hole runs this whole
thing she tells me what to do
she's also my fashion consultant if you
like my teachers no that's true no you
are I'm having goat simulator we played
goat simulator with Andy Andy and Conan
yes we've done it we they loved it dunk
machine that girl is Beth that she's I
want to get past this guy to the cool
dudes counters Jesus you're whipped
diggin the teacher today thank you Mike
cook got my old Banksy on dismaland and
the sequel you actually do fight aliens
that's not true silver Bemis rayful next
challenge [ __ ] Oh fun tiser from berlin
we've been to Berlin the Berlin episode
is airing when Beth December December
7th we do a bunch of crazy stuff we'd go
with the great Flula Borg who's
hilarious so good we've been screening a
bunch of remotes and things for our
audience it's gonna be a great episode
what are some things we do I guess we
can't say can we I know there's like
some photos to koat.com slash Berlin you
can see Conan wearing a crazy suit why
be in that suit drives in the audubon
matter by oh oh
oh I thought this guy doesn't oh he does
do an uppercut see ah he's getting me
this straight
he's gonna be a straight punch there I'm
not liking that ah I gotta get that
timing down man
he's look he's a little quick this is
von Kaiser he's a little quick off the
punch not athletic Lee slightly a little
bit ow how do I block in this damn it we
miss you we missed you we haven't on for
a while
Chakri once I get this and see my five
and seven year old boys playing these
games I'll explode with dad joy that's
one of the coolest things I think about
being a parent is you get to introduce
your kids to like awesome stoof thanks
Kirby's Dreamland would be cool Conan
did go balls out draw bad he went crazy
fast actually to the point where the guy
driving with him was a little thick
that's really good I'm really the game
in the arcades but it's from
first-person view was that true in the
arcades this is first person I don't
worry that Oh miss me oh yeah boy stoop
nice save thank you thank you
although I can swear Oh down is block
thanks Joey well look at those thighs
look at look at my massive thighs in
this game nice that's a big old big old
stems gams Oh titled out I hope you're
ready for this Beth
piston honda again slightly racist I
always want to ask you just slightly
yeah your soul diamond Coney kept
pulling games that are yes from the
Atari console yes Jesus Christ look at
this guy's head my god oh [ __ ] you can't
even reach him you're jumping hook
Oh miss me oh Jesus wait what does he do
here how do I dodge this dude wait Celia
if I hit him right when he's about to
punch that stopper
oh man guys I need some help with this
dude leave Neil deGrasse Tyson alone Oh
the arcane narrations were not Mike
Tyson's punch I just punch out and then
they made this so I hate him he comes up
ah you're right
nice job O'Malley O'Malley with the key
over there core Riggs we were in New
York City two weeks ago I don't have
East Stars
oh right when use if I hit the thing
will you ever play overwatch Arum Airmen
we played with the Game of Thrones folks
Peter Dinklage and Lena Headey they were
extremely cool counterpunch dodge them
punch got it got it mr. Honda looks like
Wayne Newton he does Kelly Wayne Newton
oh yeah
yeah why why just wait for this dude to
punch me I just punch him oh [ __ ]
ah damn it Gaby every time I get hit I
lose my stars got it a few
how come I can't do my there you go
haha it's just like folk just like Boop
they should rename this mike tyson's
Boop lame-o
ooh ah mid punch Wilin on this dude
give him a fast uppercut when he's done
yeah I'm trying bro where are my camera
crew no no no just a little too racist
for me come on guys get Conan played
Katamari Damacy I love Katamari Damacy I
want so bad for them to like redo like
redo Katamari Damacy oh you know what's
actually great is we should do this on I
discovered over the weekend which is why
I didn't leave my house that on the ps4
they released a bunch of ps2 games on
the arcade so like war of the monsters
when my favorite games ever manhunt
which maybe we'll play but I have to age
gate it because this is a brutal awful
scary game
he's another do the Riverdance Randy I
can't do that I can do like some of this
though I can do I can like it I can move
like a I don't know there's a wave for
you there's something in there
wave ocean
got a train man oh man is great
what city of that yeah it's it's New
York man it's just before the twin
towers there it is to scale by the way
yeah it's it's as high as the Empire
State Building pass key oh I remember
that bully
Ripley bully ah grab at saying I wish
that we used to do the thing where Conan
I did them up Robert Smigel actually did
that mouth quite a bit and those were
called clutch cargos and the named after
an old cook oka cartoon
flippy flap hippity hop it's nice Oh
leave this dude tonight final fantasy 15
Conan shut up to me in your show hunter
I'll get right on that
and Riku played G th - sure Oh dis dudes
coming in hot
oh he waits for me to punch
whoo it's wearing me out they'll rope it
up you boys got a little counter punch
in him see this teaches kids rhythm it
teaches kids oh wow I'm up I'm up
whoa that got real fast whoo
does lilac gloves are deadly who's that
hot grill on the MacBook I don't know
there's no grill on here oh I'm not even
looking look at my ass beat come on man
left right left right left right why I
got terrible rhythm guys oh my this is
not working my controllers not working
ah damn it
left right left Rick he punched him in
the face then left and right and he'll
go down I think we're done with this
game for now but you know what we can
save it there you go that's the greatest
thing about this you can save these
games I love it and we got one stay
there you can save four slots a thing
all right Super Mario 2 I saw a lot of
people are screaming for Super Mario 2
one of the greatest games ever made by
the way in 1988 they have yet to make a
game better than Super Mario 2 now who
do you play because here's the thing
this is the first time by the way as a
child I had a chance to choose a
character and they all have their
different things the princess can float
toads real strong Luigi does like a
giant high jump in Mario I don't know
[ __ ] he's pretty I don't know uh
Aaron's right Thank You Iceman you rock
Castlevania next Castlevania is coming
next who should I play who should I put
peach toad toad toad I'm seeing a lot of
toads we're gonna
this game is great this game was also
and I'm not gonna ruin it for people
haven't played it at the end of this
game was mind-blowing to me oh I'm
already sucking you got you a turnip
situation here oh my god this game is
this takes me back for reals
oh don't go back in the thing sorry I'm
the worst at playing games guys by the
way we have the CRT on if you could tell
yeah it looks like it looks like we're
playing on an old an old TV which is
kind of fun do not adjust your sets oh I
forgot about this oh that's right oh my
god I've totally forgotten about the
schemes I'm awesome they want to save
this for something right what I want to
use this for I can't remember you
definitely do oh this is what I wanted
that heart yeah
oh my god you guys this game is sick
remember this play kid icarus next turn
us for life dude oh [ __ ] yeah bro feel
my wrath
I can't go in here if I'm holding this
baby Dee Dee Dee I got I didn't kill
that guy did it Betty it it idiot oh by
the way the music is just so on point in
these games oh [ __ ] oh you know I think
I was supposed to use that for something
or I can do some kind of a warp or
something how do you do warp here
anybody remember
[Music]
all right okay
well take it you don't suck you were my
mildly bad where's the warp in this
there's a crazy warp I think somewhere
isn't her I know there's a warp
somewhere in this computer's our black
screen of the green fun can you show the
controller cord yes here's how long the
controller cord is you guys sure it's
this yeah and it's hard to tell it's
it's exactly like three feet it's short
as hell here hold this path it's like as
long as my arm basically which is my
arms about three feet long so it's like
this long which is not super long you
really do have to be closer I mean this
is this is how it is very short I will
said that's one thing that does kind of
suck and we're all kind of uh we're all
used to like wireless controllers so
that's not great but on the other hand
it's small and um what's happening here
across the waterfall where the warp
isn't a place you said the warp was
helpful
by the way if your kids if you're
watching you can't actually crawl on
clouds this is not this is not accurate
physically accurate scientific lacquer
looking at her thank you happiness bunny
so are you I'm gonna take this little
guy sorry I'm standing on your eyeballs
whoops oh okay I didn't miss it then
what's happening here what is this guy
again oh it's this [ __ ] egg guy I
hate these dudes this guy like gave me
nightmares when I was a kid it's got a
glass ball in his stomach
it's a weird like penis faced thing that
shoots it's like it's like a weird penis
bird it's true like is it and then you
take this glass ball and you that opens
the Hawks mouth yeah and at one point
you have to oh yeah member this you have
to like fight the Hawks I remember
there's shortcuts on the first levels I
I was asking you guys for the shortcuts
ah that's so close penis brothers shoes
white said it's true
kill him afire
in the 50s a pilot fire-pot fell through
a thundercloud the only one survived
that as far as I know actually it's not
totally true there was a woman who was
in she was either parachuting or like
she was like in a squirrel suit or
something with and got sucked up into a
hurricane and she survived it was
awesome
I'm gonna be Luigi watch you're lying
you're sorry sander put a ribbon on it
to make it a girl for me actually I
remember in the manual it says oh really
somebody sent me LAX where oh man I
forgot how much I hate Luigi in this oh
you know what you got to kill this dude
I forgot hey where's yet perfect
why no mario maker I didn't they don't
have Mario maker in this perfect
ah bees not the bees not the bees I wish
you know Tendo made the NES with more
games as a way to make more game yeah
that's true I will say having it having
the mini NES as a closed system kind of
blows however there is something
beautiful to the fact that it doesn't
need to go into the internet you know
like it's crazy it is kind of annoying I
will say you know bees bees bees bees
bees bees bees oh forgot that thing ran
out nope
Mario maker is three you only oh you
know what I remember some of the warps
on here are like you're supposed to
carry those potions I think a far far
away away
I got to meet the creator Mario Miyamoto
is awesome really nice guy that's right
I'm supposed to carry the potion over
here when the show is going to Dallas
there was a close game er in the Cowboys
Stadium oh wow there's a long time wheel
oh no it's the dude who wants his key
sorry pal
Terri's are you a fan of cherries but
perhaps a cherry cocktail named
something yeah but like on in like in
like an old-fashioned Manhattan okay
or like a sundae cherry sundaes are
great no I'm gonna cure how does this
work I gotta put this here I guess huh
damnit ah
so stupid just can't cover never joining
on streams he used to but he has it for
a while right now yeah
he'll be back one day I have to I have
to to uh the the things I asked him I
need to space out because he hates me so
they need to be slowly spaced out so I
yeah it's so it's we keep the poison i
when you're poisoning someone it's best
to do it just little by little see this
guy again I hate this dude I don't think
I don't think this guy exists anywhere
else but in Super Mario 2 am I right or
wrong
uh I'm off rhythm you know so many of
these games are just about rhythm it's
crazy
this is Luigi look a little washed out
Berto give me that heart looks like
Barney what's up Beth timing not rhythm
sorry man damn it that characters in
Mario Kart no that's not true
really are these free-range do you go
good contribute to my geriatric
delinquency we got some old fans ah
let's be let's be peach because be
choice it fly round guys we're just
joining us today we're playing the brand
new mini Nintendo here it is it's pretty
dope the it I mean the cord is a little
short but I will say this thing lives up
to the hype it's so fun and you can um
the best part is you can save your game
you have for save slots per you know for
save slots per game so you can actually
have a chance of beating these goddamn
games which when I was a kid that was
impossible
- is there something here thing is
peaches week which kind of sucks watch
this I mean I can do this in one fell
swoop
zoo oh boy whoops so I get for showing
off oh there we go I did it I found a
warp yes never get now we're on we're on
the fourth level zipped up finally I
knew there was a warp around here
somewhere what does this a my t-shirt
it's dismal and the Banksy hurts a
skylight books which is our our favorite
bookstore great smelly books best books
during the world also you know what's
weird as sky like books has it's in a
ton of commercials do you notice that
because there's like a tree in the
middle of skylight books yeah
and it's it's it's like they use it for
a lot of commercials yeah it's a good
set right it's like in the middle of
kind of in the middle of things
oh no sorry
that's just ask what a warp does but
don't hold it against her Oh what's up
here is this guy who made that weird
thing this music will never not make me
anxious
ah Jesus yeah we'd watch anything that
kid says i weirdly have a bunch of stuff
from NIC cages house in my house because
I went to a state and a state sale of
his oh yeah so I have like all these
little ceramic babies and I've got like
this weird meditation this meditation
device that you're supposed to stare at
for 15 minutes without blinking and it
spins and I also have what else I have a
pair of boxing gloves of his I have a
top hat I have a bunch of books I bought
of his and I just give that stuff away
as gifts it's like they're great gifts I
was like this isn't it was from the
cages house like what I'm a crazy person
where's RJ no one knows that's probably
RJ asking I'm sure that's RJ I'm
Blaisdell cages baby's soul stole is a
strong word I'd say borrowed that is
correct
[ __ ] that chick reading her
comments she is play altered beast
Quentin Altered Beast is Sega Genesis
get your story straight yo oh my
goodness no I didn't see any Hummels I
know
now and see I should be able to go
underneath that guy that's ridiculous
no no life's guys this is it this is for
all the cookies what game are we playing
after this is the question I just went
through that B did you see that now it's
awesome
oh come on [ __ ] double dragon after
this double dragon another game aye aye
Oh God I oh that's yeah cuz touching a
stream of water kills you
whatever lame-o ah no I say no no sir I
say no but let's save it we'll come back
this is great
this is so fun alright doc constant out
on here play some double dragon now if
we add another a double dragon - I'm
sorry The Revenge if we had this is
another by the way one that has a great
story if we had another controller which
we don't but if we did we could well I
don't know you can't get another
controller but we don't have escaped
what the guts is I don't know I bet I'm
sure mods are gonna Oh in nineteen
whatever violence is New York after a
nuclear after nuclear war even crime
scene this is growing bigger every year
people called in the double dragons
again Bubble Bobble maybe Bubble Bobble
after this sup dude sup Brian mega man -
what's up Brian controller camp was too
short
how long is the HDMI cable a jockey was
pretty long the shadow warrior Marion
was killed
yeah it's all very sad Inge against
ninja guns awesome contra I'm not
ignoring Zelda it's just we can't get
that far in Zelda Zelda is more of like
a slow burn saving on Metroid well play
Zelda on a future one we got 10 minutes
left double dragons alright let's go
oh yeah you what's in this huh
I love that you can only kick backwards
by the way in this game if you want to
kick you have to turn around because
that's how you kick I guess also you
know what's weird
okay I don't need that oh sure I think
it's got probably Van Damme in Jason
Patric oh my god I've gained my you know
what's weird is the the buttons in this
game change depending on which way
you're facing like the button closest to
the dude punches the button away like on
the other side of the furthest way kicks
backwards it's kind of hard to figure
out that uppercut
I think like you
somebody's doing cartwheels coming are
we okay
I can do that too I like how they only
choose to attack you one at a time it's
very nice of them all right let's go up
look at my hair by the way
just kill it alright here we go
ah take some nice to the face baby
yeah it's great it's it's absolutely
worth the hype if you can get one it's
really fun and it's so weird I couldn't
tell you why it's you know it's like
they have emulators and stuff but oh you
got a knife hey I think part of its like
the controller also it's like expense I
mean it would be expensive to buy these
games even now you know you got 30 and
again the best part about this is you
can save your game at this deal because
I never could be I never had a hope of
beating Double Dragon your boys gotta
always go for the dude the pipe first oh
oh sure
oh and now oh okay
it'll be a little [ __ ] about it I
haven't Sinise the face controls are a
little imperfect and Double Dragon - oh
this guy I don't remember this dude at
all
this guy oh right in the dick
damn son come on over here and I'll do a
little kick I stand up to my kick do you
damn Benitez Wheaties people still say
that eating his Wheaties oh come on not
fair it's just about it's about like
lining up the pixels perfectly oh no you
could fall off that seems like [ __ ]
but fine I got to perfect my jump here
oh damn
[Music]
what was that Dan he's got me
Goonies was a great game and a better
movie there we go
yeah boy my thoughts on call of duty my
thoughts being one FSD whoa what the I'm
doing like [ __ ] I didn't know how to do
this guy alright
disappeared yeah run away that's good
you're right Paul the controls in this
game on top they're escaping in that
chopper you'll never make it mission to
at the Healey port that doesn't seem
nearly as excited as I am but I'm
excited
what's your nostalgia like Earl Grey tea
what's your styling where do I go I go
down you were never a children you were
fully formed you just appeared one day
there was an eclipse and you just
appeared you know what I'm I'm playing
this new game called I don't need to
fight everybody oh I guess I do I guess
they're playing a game where you'll pay
times with two us have a little dick
kick huh a little dick kick whoops sorry
see as late as I think I'm gonna try
this new strategy where I could use Oh
what oh cool
yeah that's really cool great very fair
extremely fair
are you even supposed to dodge that is
it kind of messed up that like as a kid
you're supposed to hit women I'm just
punching up like being a woman in the
face that can't be good now see if I
were these dudes I would just jump out
all at once you know and why why would
you wait oh here's some dudes I've never
seen before
why don't you just send out the toughest
dudes at first like the jump kick dude
that show is great there we go miss me
ha ha this game would really benefit
from like an overhaul in like just
control so you know what I'm saying
but maybe that's how maybe that's the
part you maybe that's what stuff you
know you're just supposed to get better
a little jump kick can I get in the shop
oh hello can't we just talk about our
differences wires are all this punching
and kicking and stuff you know
also he just walks right up to me and I
just bought cheese these guys these guys
seem extremely are these ladies seem it
seems completely unfair all right I just
need that is this like a tiger person
and how do I do that flipsie doodle
thing no I died now we're back now
what's up all right anybody else coming
out of this chopper wait hey hey it's
it's a dude from clueless camera that's
true there's nucleus game around tonight
guys Final Fantasy 15 with Elijah Wood
lin-manuel Miranda from Hamilton trapper
escaped into the neon filled light this
is well written by the way a battle in
the chopper all right let's go still
can't quite get the jump kick situation
down but ah oh hey let's just just
haven't have to do over here yeah that's
easy
hey dudes come on over this way stand on
this thing hey stand on this thing
later later this is so easy
come on over here just stand right there
stand right there
no God oh Jesus he's been hitting the
gym yeah well it was worth it
at least I killed that big guy you know
yes you will absolutely will
the absatootly will all right do it for
today guys we got to end up you got a
taping at two o'clock today we got a
taping in an hour so that's gonna do
today we thanks for joining us we played
Italian a little lie Nintendo is great
again the cord is kind of short but
still absolutely worth it could you get
yeah you could save your game it's
amazing look at this see I actually have
a chance of beating Double Dragon to
which I never had before ha but yeah
there's 30 games on here and you can do
four by three you can do pixel-perfect
it's awesome you could also do what it
looked like a plan an old shitty TV very
very cool they also have you know they
have all this stuff auto-shutdown core
screen burnin reduction which means
it'll just play games where you're
playing you can also choose your you can
play in Portuguese if you want to there
you go here's some legal notices about
it yeah and also all the manuals they
have you just scan in this this is very
cool you can just scan in on any game
let's say you want to go you really want
to see the main oh for Kid Icarus why
don't I start clings here but you can
see the main go for Kid Icarus you just
go up here all the game animals are
right there which is pretty great um
that's right it's great seeing you guys
but mini yeah it's home arrow Modena
it's awesome it's amazing thank you guys
for joining us Vijay Kelly clang Russ
puss Peter donkeys Paul burger Christy
has millions for the wind Tommy
David thank you for joining us next week
make sure to watch tonight we got
foolish gamer lin-manuel Miranda and who
else is on the show hi John early the
heading the harder on tonight a great
show
TBS 11:10 central see you guys next
Monday at noon for soup
you